many hands make for light surgery or at
least that's what developer bosses
studio seems to be going for as it
expands its chaotic medical operation
simulator with the addition of
multiplayer in surgeon simulator to
rather than being confined to looming
over the same patient with your feet
firmly planted on the floor of whatever
unsterile surgery setting you're
operating in surgeon sim to opens things
up and I'm not just talking about chest
cavities the theater environment of the
game is fully explorable giving whatever
barbaric doctor you're controlling full
movement around the hospital environment
not only does this make each operation
more dynamic but it also means you'll
have to be more than swap out a monkey
heart to succeed instead of just picking
up whatever blunt object is sterile
enough to break open Bob's ribcage there
is a new emphasis on the preparation of
each medical procedure diagnosis plays a
part in figuring out not only what is
wrong with your patient but also informs
virtual doctors and nurses what tools
you're likely to need and whether you
should pick up a few spare legs and arms
just in case levels are open to
exploration with many tools medicines
and vital organs are hidden behind
puzzles locks behind doors or sometimes
only accessible through strange vents
and back passages not only does this
play into the emphasis of preparing your
tools and workspace for virtual surgery
but it also allows players the
opportunity to tackle each patient in
their own way
for example while some will want to make
every preparation and collect every
obscure tool they think they'll need
others may go for the speedier option of
tearing lungs out with their bare hand
preparation however will make things
easier using the right tool for the job
will decrease blood loss improving your
patient's chance of survival as you'll
be well equipped if they start bleeding
out on you brute forcing a medical
procedure using your singular strange
hand or trying to hammer a pancreas will
increase how much blood Bob is losing so
therefore you had better be quick lest
he be dead and while it still remains a
challenge to complete each operation it
is more rewarding to do so utilizing the
freedom of movement and increased level
of dexterity that comes with your brand
new version of the classic surgeon
simpler ting arm all of this is elevated
by surgeon sim twos new multiplayer
dynamic as it plays into both the
preparation before the actual surgery as
well as feeling right at home with the
chaotic
and bizarre physics the franchise is
known for multiplayer makes the game
feel like a working theater or beer an
extremely cursed one having your
partners help with diagnosis and system
puzzles monitor vitals or even go away
to fetch spare limbs and organs works
brilliantly it feels like the havoc
filled cooperative experience we've seen
in games like overcooked or human full
flats but this time oh so much bloodier
and hilariously more McCobb there will
likely be more levels to play and
medical procedures to undertake this
time around as well as basa has said
it's releasing the very same level tools
it used to build the game allowing
players to create their own puzzles and
strange treatments for others to
download and play themselves I'm
imagining it to be a little like mario
maker but with less goombas and more
people trying to put legs where they
don't belong and while boss is trying to
build upon the supposed law of the
surgeons in franchise with interesting
story tidbits through the official
levels surgeon sim too seems to be
focusing on it's entertaining new
features and remaining true to the core
gameplay that helped make original oh so
popular been released back in 2013 so
for those that reveled in the strange
machinations of the first game the main
takeaway should be that surgeons seem to
seems to have remained the Daft odd
physics based surgery sandbox you
remember with just a bit more sprinkled
on top
surgeon simulator releases August 2020
and is available to pre-order for beta
access on the epic storm right now if
you have any questions that weren't
covered in the video leave them in the
comment section and I'll do my best to
jump in there and answer them and to
keep updated on this game and dozens of
others across the coming months then be
sure to use that unwilled lee
disembodied hand to hit subscribe
you